this is one of Portugal's best-kept
secrets come porta in Allen Teja region
it's long and solitary beaches stretch
as far as the eye can see the area isn't
commercially developed and is often
overlooked by European tourists a big
draw in Alentejo is observing dolphins
in an estuary off the Atlantic coast
about 27 dolphins reside here
those with patience and sturdy sea legs
just might get a chance to see them on a
special boat tour
[Music]
well the Dolphins are something very
special that is in the border of
Alentejo in close to the sea because
it's the only place in Portugal where
it's possible to do a dolphin watching
for a resident group of community
resident in an estuary something very
particular and different another unique
sight is the historical part of
comported with hundreds of uneven planks
and wooden stakes it is served as
anchorage two boats for over two
centuries Allen Teja covers a vast
region in central Portugal a bulk of the
region contains rice fields vineyards
and cork plantations agriculture is key
to the local economy located about a
two-hours drive east from the coast is
the walled town of Evera
it's home to about 57,000 people here
tourism helps boost the local economy
ever as moreish alleyways various
architectural examples and it's Roman
temple helped it earn UNESCO World
Heritage status so we are on the top of
the hill where 2,000 years ago the
Romans built their temple and this is
the picture of the city that in a short
area has examples of 2,000 years of
history with constructions from
different periods up to modern age and
this is the reason why travelers must
not skip visiting this world heritage
city
another fascinating but grisly tourist
attraction is ever as the so-called
Chappell of bones I have a message for
you it's only for brave hearts the Bell
standing here awaiting for yours follow
me
this is one of the best-known monuments
in Evra the chapel was meant as a
meditation spot for monks but 400 years
ago they decided to move the bones of
more than 5000 commoners to this final
resting place
back in the land of the living every
also offers a cozy culinary environment
it's common to find locals who own and
run the restaurants in the center of
town the most important dish from
Alentejo the name it's migas it's the
rolled bread with meat pork it's very
very typical and also everybody the
local people the old people they eat
this every day every week
migas consists of breadcrumbs sautéed in
garlic and olive oil they're stirred
until they soak up the oil once rolled
the meat is added and in this case pork
now this dish may be a common staple for
the locals but tourists enjoy it too as
part of the local Flair
Allen Teja was home to some 70 wineries
mostly red wine is produced here since
the area gets some 3,000 hours of
sunshine per year the conditions for
growing grapes are ideal here we have 12
different grape varieties we have here
it's Cabernet Sauvignon we have
recognized also we have two Coderre we
have Syrah to recognize you now it's
very well known here in Atlanta we use a
lot in our blends and these are the most
known one from the wine country and
culture and ever on to the beaches of
comfort on the allant asian region of
Portugal offers a relaxing getaway at
any time of the year
[Music]